Tony Dungy MBC football night in America
analyst joining us on behalf of all pro
dad which is partnering with the Florida
Department of Education for take your
child to school day on September 26
though through all pro dad the chapters
nationwide parents can be active in
their child's school not just this month
but every month and Tony joins us
courtesy of the Continental Tire Coaches
Corner
hey coach how are you hey I'm doing well
and I was on both sides of that Dan
Marino situation we had still had Terry
Bradshaw was my third year I think
coaching with the Steelers we test on
Marino and the 83 draft and you're right
I think he was split in time with David
would lead maybe at the time and they
hoped Shula brought him in and he played
great that rookie year second year he
he'd probably got half of those
touchdown passes on us he drew a bunch
of against us as to gags I saw it live
and up close did you Scout what was your
job title with the Steelers back then I
was a defensive assistant but I don't
net that I never forget Marino had a
great junior year a little bit of
subparts people thought senior year and
he still played very well but he lit it
up as a junior in the senior he didn't
they came over we brought his two
receivers Julius Dawkins and Dwight
Collins over for a workout at Three
Rivers Stadium it was cold and the wind
was blowing a hundred miles an hour and
those balls were just riesling through
the wind right on target and Julius
Dawkins dropped every ball that came to
him and I remember thinking to myself I
know why he had a little bit of a
downswing
[Laughter]
but we knew and we knew all about him
and loved him coach snow loved him but
we still had Bradshaw at the time and so
it just didn't seem like the right thing
to do he went to Miami you know at the
back end of the draft Miami still had a
very good team and it was just a perfect
situation but do you see any parallels
between the Steelers back then that you
don't want to bring in your replacement
for Terry Bradshaw hall-of-famer and
what's going on with the Giants that
they could have drafted Sam darn 'old as
the successor to Eli Manning
that's one thing that stuck with me than
the rest of my career if you get a
chance if you have someone that you
think is a franchise quarterback and you
have a chance to draft and you need to
draft them no matter what else is on
your roster
we didn't take Dan Marino and for 20
years
Ben Roethlisberger they were still
trying to get quarterbacks and we went
through a ton of them and so when I got
to Minnesota and worked for Denny green
he had the same philosophy he drafted
some daunte culpepper when they had
Randall Cunningham Brad Johnson Jeff
jours on the roster it doesn't matter if
you think that guy is legit and for real
and you have a chance to take and you
better take I had a couple of questions
we had a poll question if you are a
player would you rather play for Bill
Belichick or Mike Tomlin I know a little
bit I think most players would say Mike
Tomlin but I know a little bit more
about Bill Belichick through Rodney and
rhotic says you can't go by everything
he had a lot of fun playing football
it's like of course you're going to win
there that's a tough question I don't
think I and you always get me to answer
I don't think I can answer that one
because I like Mike Tomlin style you
know being around Mike I probably have
to say I'd rather play for Mike but is
he too easygoing I wonder if his
personality has led to this where he has
big personalities and it feels like
those big personalities some sometimes
get out of hand you know I don't know I
don't think he's too easygoing I think
it's I think he tries to treat people
like men and sometimes that backfires on
you when you have guys that aren't men
yet and he probably does need to go to
Antonio Brown and say look you know you
got to just chill with all this social
media you've got to get on board and
tighten things up and you know maybe he
needs to do that but III think his flaw
if anything is trying to treat them like
adults now this thing with Antonio Brown
is
a big deal is you know I remember I came
to Pittsburgh as a rookie in 1977 Mel
Blanc was holding out he had been the
defensive player here on 75 givest for
$100,000 and he was holding out and they
said we couldn't noway wouldn't a
defensive player that much and then they
had this trial georgeanna canson sued
Chuck Noll and Chuck had made a criminal
element comment and then I guess when
the lawyers said well don't you have
some criminal element on your team it
goes bill so when you have melt Luckett
fall into that category so Belle said
hey I've never played for the Steelers
again and I asked some of the players
that's a man I came to falling apart
here Mel player of the year he's never
gonna play for the Steelers again and
they said don't worry as soon as the
national anthem and the fight ball
he'll be back again sir does he was and
we want a couple for a Super Bowl so I
think a lot of that get blown out of
proportion
I don't remember Chuck Noll being
involved in a lawsuit with the Raiders
George Atkinson where he oh yeah it was
huge yeah Atkinson actually went after
Swan and just you know really stuff that
you you'd be suspended for life now if
some of those hits and coach snow said
well they've got a criminal element on
the tee and then Atkinson and Tatum I
think those guys ended up suing Coates
know there's a big trial out in
California right for the 77th season
yeah oh so defamation of character is
that what it was or Slayer yeah exactly
here's again those some of those hits
now guys wouldn't even be able to be
allowed on the field now and they were
just everyday commonplace hits like then
which leads me to clay Mathews tackle
and we were discussing it yesterday you
were kind enough to tweet and you had
some thoughts about this but just that
play alone if I look at the play given
today's rules because if we're using you
know last year's then it's probably
different but today's rules should Clay
Matthews have been flagged for that hit
on Kirk Cousins I don't think so because
in my opinion he didn't kick him up and
drive him down he didn't put his whole
body weight he didn't try fence at the
chart he picked him up and and they slid
and it was more of a parallel going to
the ground so I didn't think it fell
under any of the categories but as I
said and I told you yesterday it's like
a basketball referees and baseball
umpires you have to know who's calling
the game and what type of game they're
calling Tony curenci had called that hit
it personal foul on the Vikings earlier
so you've got to be smart enough to say
hey they're calling them tight today
I've got to understand that you know if
you have different reference we used to
have scouting report our defensive line
coach would come in and say hey here is
you know the referees we've got today
Jerry often he's called seven roughing
the passer penalties in the last eight
games
he's called two-step violation he's
called driving the quarterback and this
is what he looks for blow to the head so
you've not going to be able to do that
hey this referee is only called one
roughing the passer all year you've got
a little more freedom and but right now
with these new rules the players don't
know that yet they'll get an idea of
what each referee calls and they'll
they'll adjust and and and I think
you'll see less ton of these as we go
forward but that's what I don't
understand Tony if a strike is a strike
in baseball and if pass interference or
holding or you know roughing the passer
I mean it feels like they those have
definitions you know a strike zone is
there is a zone there but we have
umpires and referees and officials who
have their own interpretation to that
why do we allow open to interpretation
well I think it's the way the rule has
is drawn up when you say the rule says
you can't forcibly drive them into the
turf well to me that my definition of
what's forcible and what's really
driving against the turf might be
different than it is for you and that's
where that's where it comes up before I
let you go all pro
dad if you'd like to explain what you
and your wife are doing with all pro dad
here's a real neat organization actually
started down here in Tampa in 1998
several of our coaches we were trying to
figure out how we could spend a little
more time with our kids given the
schedule then we came over to family
first and got some good ideas and some
good information and then we had an
event at the at our training camp
practice and back then we weren't very
good we're getting about 50 people a day
coming out to watch this practice and we
said hey Dez bring your kids out and
enjoy some time with the family and
watch this play and we'll give away some
some events and you'll get to meet some
of the players and we had about 4,000
people how they came so we said hey
getting men and who might be interested
in football might be a good idea and so
it started then and it's grown and now
we're just involved we've got a great
website all-pro dead calm where men can
go to get ideas on how they can connect
better with with their children and be a
better dad that's great
speaking of our Tampa has Ryan
Fitzpatrick are in this job you know I
think he has and I was at their training
camp two weeks ago right before the
regular season started they knew what
was coming but I'll tell you what they
had tremendous confidence because the
organization built this name around
Jameis Winston they draft him number one
and they said we're going to give him
some weapons so they got Mike Evans as a
talented big receiver they went out and
got DeSean Jackson to speak at a drafted
OJ Howard
so there's weapons there and what Ryan
has done he knows the game he knows the
other team's weaknesses he knows where
to throw the ball and they saw this
coming they said hey we might not win
every game but we're going to put up
points while Jameis is out and now that
they're winning I think you got to stay
with it how bad how much trouble the New
York Giants in I was that offensive line
they're in a lot of trouble I picked
them I thought they would win against
Dallas because I thought Eli would have
four weapons to throw the ball tooth and
dak Prescott head but you got fake Juan
Barkley who
having trouble getting back to the line
of scrimmage he had the one long run but
he broke about six tackles on that run
they're not able to pass protect and
give Eli time until they get that
offensive line straight out they're
gonna have a tough time winning yeah I
don't think they're getting that
offensive line straighten out this year
to show up to play for no no they take
Big John Hicks right now good to visit
with you tell the boys tell Mike and rod
I said hello Thank You tone I will we
miss the DP that's a Tony Dungy football
night in America for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
at
[Music]